foreign
you told me we're gonna kick off today
with the lightning round
oh my God
ah fantastic
I would have got a velvet coat man or a
lava lamp that was good man I like that
some Swisher Sweets that would have been
good dude way to go
fantastic all right so lightning round
so if you for those of you who have
never been with us on a lightning round
I have absolutely 100 no idea what
they're about to ask and so they're just
gonna bring the Thunder
it which is a terrible thing to say for
the uh sex intimacy you're gonna you're
gonna ask a lot of questions yes and
these are all under the sex and intimacy
category awesome so buckle up everybody
but let's let's go or unbuckle there you
go yeah all right let's do it all right
the first one what do you mean when you
say that you have to practice desire
oh man
um
we as a culture we worship at the altar
of our feelings and so we think that if
I don't feel quote unquote in love I
don't feel quote unquote attracted I
don't feel whatever that that is the end
all be all that's the truth and that's
it's feelings are very very important
they're important signals that you need
to feel and ask yourself what are they
telling you same as if you're driving on
the road and there's flashing neon signs
in front of you while you're driving in
traffic you need to look at those signs
but that's not the destination that's
not where you're going right so when it
comes to practicing desire what I mean
is
desire over time is a choice it is
something not that is just like it's not
a whim it's not just a well it's just
the way that is no dude practicing
desire is important and so I'm gonna
practice
taking care of myself so that I'm I'm my
best I'm gonna practice
um meeting my partner's needs I'm gonna
practice leaning in and having hard
conversations or really sexy intimate
conversations Etc so that's practicing
together that's what I mean when I say
that
all right you've mentioned before that
some people can't have sex with dirty
dishes in the sink
how do I find without how do I find out
what those things are for my spouse
oh ready this is good I went to a lot of
grad school for this this answer
um
drum roll please America
you ask ta-da
um I think I think if you are a couple
on the same page you're a couple that's
like hey here's where we are with our
sex life and here's what we would like
it to be
we want it to be less
um chores less
um like I got a checklist and more let's
see if we can get the wallpaper to peel
itself off the wall right that's that's
run ahead
the conversation often couples jump in
and they start with what sex act do you
want to try and that's fun that's
exciting it's it's a blast but I
wouldn't recommend starting there most
of the time most the time you back up
and say okay
what is a world where you feel the most
sexy
if you go back to the last two or three
times four or five times when you have
I've gotten home and you just want to
get it on what was going on in that
world and want to begin to listen to our
bodies as we move forward so if you find
yourself about to get it on and you're
thinking about the dishes call it out
because we're practicing this thing
together as we move forward so call that
out or dude I've just got to go make
sure the downstairs basement's locked up
oh okay weird but go make sure it's
locked up or maybe next time I'm gonna
make sure it's locked up before I head
upstairs so listen to your body over
time
cool all right my spouse over shares
about our relationship to his family and
friends how do I tell him to stop
again man you lucked out with a genius
like me hang on to your hats America
tell him to stop
ta-da I
number one tell them stop number two
here's how I would frame that
um I don't feel safe
when parts of my intimate private life
are shared among other people it makes
me feel exposed and unsafe please don't
make me feel unsafe
that is a language that is different
than I don't want you to or why do you
that's different
um get to the root of why you don't want
someone to know and it may be it may be
like you can get to the bottom of me
like I don't know I'm just overreacting
I just think talking about sex is weird
and I guess it's not
um that might be you and it might be I
you feel so viscerally exposed you feel
uncomfortable you feel whatever the
thing is
um speak there not just at the I want my
way but at the here's how you make me
feel
I feel like that buzzer is like saying
wrong answer it's so good it is a bit
hard wrong
all right so if your partner initiates
sex but you don't want to at that moment
should you still do it
man why you gotta set me up like that
um
uh jeez this one's a tricky one
so here's how it is I'll answer this in
multiple ways
if you don't want to because your
partner hurts you or you are being
abused or you know your partner or
assume your partner is cheating on you
it might be bringing somebody else's
diseases into your bed or whatever
no
absolutely not
if
you or somebody man or woman I don't
care who takes some time to warm up or
you're tired you're not quote unquote
feeling it right now
but you know over time if you just like
Let It Ride you start getting into it
then you're you're never glad that you
you're never not glad that you went
ahead and did it right so if that's you
then yes then I need to know I'm really
tired right now I just want to go to bed
I am not going to regret in fact I'm
gonna really be happy myself with myself
if we go ahead and do this and I can
tell my partner's really into it so
um it that's not a is that a safe answer
I don't be safe answer but it feels
right
yes because I think that's where the
question's Leaning it's that
you know everybody's safe in the room
and everything like that but does that
man I'm so tired but then like you said
but I'm always glad we do exactly
halfway through I'm like okay this was a
much better decision than watching the
office right right
um I think listen to your body and also
be honest with yourself like if you know
in 10 or 15 minutes you're gonna be glad
you're into this then go for it man
um and it goes back to that idea like
feelings are important signals but
they're not truth tellers and
um yeah I really want to just double
click on the on the abuse thing man if
you don't feel like it because you're
not safe because you just like your
partner doesn't care about your needs at
all and it's all about him getting off
or her what if if that's the case not in
that moment but you need to have a
conversation about a much harder broader
conversation
all right this one's a little longer so
bear with me
what do you mean when you tell partners
that their spouse is not something to
fix
when an individual in a relationship has
baggage that they need to work through
how do you do this without coming at
them from a fixing standpoint
um
the best example I gave you is last
night my my wife and I went for a long
walk like we like we've we've started
doing the last year or so and they're I
just love it
um we're going for a long walk and she
was walking me through some things she's
been thinking through and working
through and I said
could I give you a word of caution
and her response was no thank you
and I had to
exhale for a second
and then move on with my day and it was
a bold moment of strength for her to say
no thank you
and I was trying to love her the best I
could but what she didn't need for me in
that moment evident by her telling me so
was my Wiz my my wisdom my advice my
answers what she needed was a safe place
to tell what she's working through what
she's thinking about what she's feeling
and what she's going to do next and part
of Love often is letting somebody
do their thing and to be with them when
they're doing it to be with them when
it's super successful and be with them
when it falls in on itself and so
um I I think go back to the original
question there oh about fixing
I think all of this can be solved with a
very simple phrase seek to be
um
with not over
when you start giving advice
the posture everything about advice is I
know something you don't know I'm in an
elevated position from you
I can see what's happening and you can't
um that is different than I'll sit here
with you I know what I would do but man
I don't have all the answers either and
I'm not you and seek to be with seek to
be with seek to be with
um husbands especially have a tendency
we just are loved by our utility what
can you do you're a human doing right
and so when people in our lives are
hurting we just want to go fix it wanna
make it right because that's how we
achieve love
that's not how relationships work over
time
foreign
ER wants to try something new in the
bedroom and I'm not comfortable with it
what should I do
see I'm not comfortable with it
um I think there's a uh again this isn't
every couple and there's jerks and
idiots everywhere
um
often I think when couples get stuck on
like I want to try this one sex move I
want to try this one position I'll try
this one thing
um the instant response is I'm not doing
that sometimes that response is I'm not
doing that because I've never seen it I
don't even know what are you talking
about that sounds weird that sounds like
it's going to be awful it's whatever
you're feeling so you're instantly
trying to protect yourself which is
which is great
um
and your partner can often feel like
oh there's there's a part of me that you
don't love because I'm interested in
this and you're not right so you get
this weird tension often I've seen that
diffused with
like some laughter and some okay like
what do you why do you want to do that
like what is it about that thing and
often there's some eroticism around
talking about well I would feel good if
and I want to try this and I think you
are filling the blank like getting to
the bottom of why you want to try that
what you're thinking about what are some
alternative things we could do or I'll
try this instead of that becomes an
erotic conversation in and of itself if
you'll allow it if it doesn't become
this uh Ike fight like I want to do this
and you never let then you're just an
idiot but if you are really getting to
the bottom of how do you why do you want
to try that
um
then I think I think I think you can get
there and it's a lot more fun
all right on the flip side of that how
do you bring up something new that you
want to try but you're unsure if your
partner will be comfortable comfortable
with it
so I have developed I didn't develop
anything
um
so two years ago I did a live event uh
and I said hey here's what everyone
needs to do um it's for it's gonna cost
like 15 cents go to Walgreens and buy
like 10 or 15 just envelopes empty
envelopes and I call it the John deloney
erotic envelope system and go buy 10 or
15 envelopes get note cards and you get
five and she gets five you get seven and
she gets them whatever
and just write down
what something you want to you want to
do
whatever
let the what do you let the freak flag
fly whatever like I really want to try
this I want to try this I want to try
this and
uh is my wife put in one time I just
opened it up and oh here's like once a
month once a week whatever just commit
we're gonna give it the old College try
we're gonna open this up and we're gonna
figure this out it may not work it may
be a disaster but we're gonna go into it
with a spirit of exploration and fun and
laughter and not a and again going back
to if you open it up and you're like I
don't know how this is physically pot
like what have that conversation make
that a fun like how does this even what
are you talking about right have that
conversation uh my wife one time uh
she put on one french kissing
I felt like I got robbed I was just
French kissing she's like we used in
college we just french kissed and I like
that and I miss it
so that was in the envelope and that's
what we did
just held hands and
made out it was awesome so anyway all I
have to say is put whatever you want in
there I just want to go hold your hand
on 30 minutes I Want to Hold Your Hand
that's it that's it put it in the
envelope
um then what happens kind of questions
for humans it ends up being
I'm not the weird one the card is the
weird thing right so just a little bit
of deflection there where the card can
take some of the
what
um and let it let it roll what I will
tell you is this if you have something
you want to try or a couple of different
sex acts that your partner's not doing
and you want to get you
if you try over the course of two months
five months two years ten years to him
haul your way through it
or to like kind of subtly or not so
subtly encourage it
you're setting up you're going to be
disappointed your partner is going to be
is going to know they're not doing
something right and they're not going to
know what it is and they're not going to
know how to talk about it you are
setting yourself up on a track of this
function don't do that don't hold
Secrets just say I want to try this
thing hopefully over time you develop
enough rapport with the person I don't
know you're going to make humans with
that you buy a house with that you can
say hey I'm into this thing I'm gonna
try it give it a shot give it a shot
that's all and also don't bully oh for
sure tell me more about that well just
don't bully your partner into well I
want to and you don't I don't get what I
want or you know if you love me stupid
and cowardly and lame yeah yeah
um yes don't don't be like that
absolutely just don't be like that
anywhere anywhere in Life or passive
aggressive like I guess you just don't
love me don't be like that it just gives
me the heebie-jeebies I hate passive
aggressiveness anyhow uh my spouse and I
don't share any of the same Hobbies so
we don't spend any free time together
how can we find something that we both
enjoy doing that was it what a great
question
um and I'm laughing because you have
whoever wrote the question has
bifurcated themselves into
they've backed themselves into a corner
and they've thrown their hands up and
they're like well we don't like any of
the same things and so now we don't we
don't get to spend time together
I would flip that around and say and say
we're gonna spend time together and with
the time we have left we're gonna spend
on our Hobbies right
um or maybe one day I do Hobbies one day
we spend time doing things together and
I think you figure out things that you
like to do together over time
um for me and my wife often it's
reading a book next to each other
that's it because I don't like her books
she doesn't like my books we don't
listen to the same podcast we don't
listen to say like we have very
different like I play guitar she likes
to Garden we have very different things
that we do
um and so we have worked over time to
find those things where we can spend
time together and we have to be really
intentional about it and by the way
you just figured out over time and so
it's something you practice like man
I've been trying to
I mean she watched fights with me for
years she tried man she tried eventually
she's like all those guys are super
ripped they look great but I just I
gotta I want to go to bed and so I get
it and there's other things I've tried
like I'll try I'll try I just can't I I
so you give it a shot you give it a shot
and you practice and you try and then
you move on I think this I'm gonna say
this
I think we make
every encounter the Super Bowl
every time we have sex it's the Super
Bowl it has to be mind-blowing both
people have to have an orgasm both
everything has to be just like this and
if it doesn't we start immediately going
okay what's wrong what didn't happen
right what
dude
if you spend most of your life like most
of life is a scrimmage we're just
practicing and figuring out it's so much
more fun you drop the ball in the
scrimmage like you and your friends
laugh at you you're teammates like idiot
it's not end of time it's not like in
front of 90 000 people or whatever
um it's so I think making taking the
pressure off of you and your spouse and
your friends
um on all things in your life man we're
just we're just fumbling through this
thing
that leads really nicely into this next
question oh look how cute that is to you
my fiance and I are about to get married
and we've saved ourselves for marriage
how do we not so put so much pressure on
one night
I I think it's insane
to not put pressure on that night it's
gonna be there like you know what I mean
um
to try to depressurize that situation is
is I wouldn't waste that energy the
energy I would expend would be talking
about it
super directly
and that might be weird if you were
waiting until
um you get married to enter into a
sexual relationship you may not have
spent a lot of time talking about it
here's what it's going to be like and my
friend told me it was like this
um talk to people in your life that you
trust who are down the road from you I
talk to other couples
um not maybe another couples but
individuals
have that conversation with each other
so there's some understanding of what
this thing might look like and by the
way it will be totally different than
you think and so I would head into it
that way and with the goal being
connectivity and closeness not
performance
across the board
is that fair it is but can I add
something you can add of all things
um
for the actual wedding night itself
you're exhausted oh you're so tired keep
that in mind that you're exhausted
because you've been planning this
wedding and this thing and it's huge and
it's a full day of family it's just a
it's a lot of a day it's an exhausting
day you probably when you're married you
probably wouldn't do it on that day any
other time throughout your history never
no because you'd be like I'm so tired I
don't I've been around people all day
long like I just want to go to bed yeah
so you probably wouldn't so that's what
I mean like you put so much pressure
like it's gonna be there because after
the wedding after all this stuff all the
people all those little yellow mints all
everything
all the dancing then you're like on the
right home to the hotel you're like I
guess this is happening like a whole
other
I've had some friends of mine that have
made agreements beforehand of you know
what we're going to be so tired in the
wedding we're not even going to get out
of there until midnight
it's not gonna happen that night let's
party let's just call that
and then but that goes about talking
about it exactly right that goes about
like talking about it and
um I think it's like how do you what you
know we talk about pictures and words on
the show how do you picture
do you picture me taking off your
clothes do you picture you taking them
all like how do you like let's
let's have that conversation and that
way you don't end up having I'm saying
that and I'm watching these like hearts
fly around my heads in through the
monitor here it's so surreal but like I
think the more conversation you can have
the more you can set each other's
expectation and you can match your
pictures and words because again and I
was just doing an interview before the
show we're in the first generation
raised entirely on pornography right and
so somebody's gonna walk into that room
with an expectation of
something that's not real right and then
somebody may not be connected to
pornography at all or somebody may have
been like I don't know what I'm doing
and they went down to pornography rabbit
hole and they so I think setting
expectations intentionally is good and
by the way talking about sex can be one
of the most intimate fun hilarious
sexy things you can do if you can
develop the the ability to have that
conversation between yourselves all
right last one
the things that turned my spouse on and
the things that turned me on are
completely different
how do we find common ground
sometimes you
participate in somebody else's fantasy I
think you in and I use fantasy brought I
guess if you don't dress up like Pirates
dressed up like Pirates but I'm saying
more like I
um I I just I'm just working with
couples like one like really gets in the
mood from like holding hands and
touching and it's quiet and then
somebody else like wants somebody to
take charge and somebody else wants
somebody to just feel like it so I think
it's a saying those needs out loud and B
um tonight we're gonna have I really
want to have boring married sex I wanna
have just regular boring marriage sex
tonight I really want to have some sort
of storyline I want to have some sort of
thing that's out there
um that I've conjured up in my head that
I want to like participate with you like
so I think it's a matter of there's some
give and take there
um and then if if there's some things
again going back to the original
question if we just feel uncomfortable
um I think you need to say out loud like
these things are making me uncomfortable
okay so that's it all right that was the
last one you did a very nice job wraps
up the lightning round